الى سوريا حيث قالت وكاله اوسان الرسميه
ان اسرائيل نفذت عدوانا جويا فجر اليوم
بعدد من الصواريخ من اتجاه البحر المتوسط
غرب اللاذقيه استهدف محيط مطار حلب الدولي
ادى الى وقوع اضرار ماديه في المطر بينما
امتنعت اسرائيل عن نفسه او تاكيد تورطها
في الهجوم الذي يعد الثاني الذي يستهدف
مطار حلب منذ بدايه الشهر الماضي
معنى الامن
مراسل الجزيره عمر الحوراني نرحب عمر
المزيد حول هذا القصف الاسرائيلي ان صحت
المعلومه على مدار ح
نعم بالفعل هذا القصف وبحسب مصدر عسكري
تابع للنظام فانه استهدف مطار حلب الدولي
في تمام الساعه الثالثه وخمسه وخمسين
دقيقه وهذا القصف ادى الى تضرر المطار ولم
تتحدث مصادر النظام عن وقوع خسائر بشريه
بل تحدثت عن وقوع خسائر ماديه وبحسب
المؤسسه العامه للطيران فانها باشرت اصلاح
المطار لكي يعود للخدمه وهذه ليست المره
الاولى التي يتم فيها استهداف هذا المطار
في السابع من الشهر الجاري ايضا تم
استهداف المطار واخراجه على الخدمه
وخلال يومين اعيد تاهيل هذا المطار وعاده
للعمل
والضربات
الاسرائيليه هي خمس ضربات منذ مطلع هذا
العام منها ثلاث ضربات استهدفت المطارات
في الثاني من يناير كانون في يناير كانون
الثاني كان هناك استهداف لمطار دمشق
الدولي وايضا في الثامن عشر من فبراير
شباط الماضي ايضا تم استهداف موقع في كفر
سوسه في دمشق وايضا في خلال هذا الشهر
بالاضافه الى الضربات التي استهدفت مطار
حلب الدولي كان هناك استهداف في الثاني
عشر من هذا الشهر لمواقع ايرانيه في ريفي
طرطوس وحماه وهذه الهجمات تكون بشكل مستمر
كان هناك عشرات الهجمات خلال السنه
الماضيه استهدفت مواقع التابعه لايران
ومثل هذه الضربات تستهدف اما مواقع
لايرانيه او لقوات تدعمها ايران او تستهدف
شحنات اسلحه ناتي الى سوريا ان كان عبر
البر او عبر المطارات مطار دمشق ومطار حلب
وايضا يتم استهداف مواقع عسكريه اخرى في
بالقرب من الاراضي المحتله جنوب سوريا
وهذه ضربات تكثفت خلال السنه السنوات
الماضيه على مواقع تابعه
لايران وايضا التحالفه الدولي يستهدف
مواقع ايضا على الحدود السوريه العراقيه
في حلب الشمالي مراسل الجزيره عمر
الحوراني